we know in animals they're served you
know for so-called instinctive and I
think you know I tell everyone I think
this century which has another 90 years
to run will be the century you know
where in psychology we becomes the
science you know that when our chief
focus will move let's say hopefully
after we've got on top of most cancer
toward understanding healthy you know
why we behave differently and you know
you know very practical things trying to
do better ways to stop depression and so
on so you know most psychology
departments we get near them or you know
not science departments and so young
people said well you have to have
something called cognitive science I'd
like to believe you know that the people
would actually like to know the truth
about themselves but there certainly
some people who would not want you to
study whether you know in any we've been
in women are different you know and seen
if you discover differences they'll just
perpetuates wrong behavior like always
they don't want to really measure
intelligence because they don't want
intelligence to be something you're born
with as opposed to having to
having it been largely determined by how
you grow up
so psychology departments now are you
know just not as bad as anthropology but
almost as bad just totally dominated by
political correctness which to me you
know in the past political correctness
has never been a way to move toward the
truth
it's like you know saying something is
religiously corrected you start from
that
yes you know how much they are well we
know very little you know the but
because we don't want to pinpoint some
people was unable to learn unless it's
so bad that you know you have to we're
sort of avoiding maybe learning somehow
and someday make our brains work better
I'm worried now that you in life in day
by day life has got more difficult
because it's just so complex and that
more and more people aren't really equal
to the complexities of current life and
I think it may underlie this you know
awful phenomena of the rich people
getting so rich because they're just
using their you know innate intelligence
to think faster and to seize
opportunities faster and you know there
could be other words last time my wife
and I went and saw Wall Street yep far
from perfect bubbly but the silly stop
provoking
and the intelligence on the intelligence
test men do worse and verbal things and
they're able to do spatial things better
and this has been related whether
correctly wrongly to our past
evolutionary role as hundred gathers
well we really had to strike out and be
able to find home against so we had to
really look at visual clues and think of
all constantly where we are where women
were you know staying in a fixed place
whether that's right or wrong but the
truth is and that we only have IQ tests
which make the fixes essentially the
same because we adjust the tests so that
they contain some questions which girls
will do better on and some words for a
boy and you could bias the test and that
is one secksy oh there was we called the
brightest there's a the fact that
there's at the ends of these curves of
intelligence there are more boys many
more mentally retarded boys and girls
and it's extreme highest level but not
really very important this anymore boy
you know true math geniuses but true
math genius is so often accompanied by
you know strange behavior antisocial
behavior it's not clear that people who
really want to give birth to boys had
those ends of the curves either end